by the way i'm just going to pass this
around as i do it can you actually hold
these up for me I want you to physically
hold these up and it's actually
important that you sort of feel what
it's like in your hands can you just do
that just possible as you still work and
they've got to me try and hold them at
the ends because the lengths actually
matter if you can I know targeting leave
it exact but we we will talk about
decimals in a second just because
decimals gives a better idea for the
scale of things aren't but you're
pre-empting the next steps okay can
someone give me t 1 in terms of T to
route 70 three how we make that simpler
yeah rue21 thank you okay now this is
what you should get after you turn these
around making the right subject etc now
I just have a question for you most of
you have calculators out of your desks I
have no idea what route 21 is let alone
what route 21 of the six years can
someone tell me about the decimal is
your boy one point your boy I mean
honeymoon what is this whole thing
colleges their minds
okay now I just want to ask you does
that thing does that make sense does
that make sense now look at what's going
on here which one is longer which one is
longer a POV p a p is on it is longer
right and we're safety ones over here
and teachers over here now if AP is
longer does it make sense that the
tension on that string should be less
than the tension can be of this stream
now admittedly we don't think very much
and this is exactly why I'm asking you
to all these ok we're going to think
about this kind of problem very much but
if you literally hold them and as you
make one of these links shorter and
shorter and as you make this ratio more
and more extreme ok you're going to find
this become more and more extreme that's
where it comes from all right I've got
an expression further our horizontal
forces together what about a vertical
expression someone tell me what to write
939 point
thanks haha ok so this is what i'm going
to write what I think I'm are equal
right now I am honey ok now let me just
explain why I'm writing it like this you
will see plenty of like worth exercises
and the next was like oh there they'll
write this with just some difference one
step forward the weapon 9.8 on this side
ok obviously these are equivalent ok the
reason why will anyone ask you guys can
you see a reason why this is actually
nice up but having the 9.8 on the other
side I or you can over the river tuna
but anyone want to give me a suggestion
ok so number one this tells you this
tells you what's going on it tells you
hear all the Fosters and I added them
all up and there should be zero because
the things not moving secondly what I
like about this is that this like it
preserves the signs of what's going on
it tells you these guys are up and this
one is down whereas what's this guy's
going over there they could both be
positive with me- like which ones which
I have no idea okay this one is a little
more meaningful now that I've got that
I'm just going to simply put this here
i'm going to substitute t 1 and that
i'll allow me to solve the teacher so my
first line i look like this hard times
what is this room 2106 and i am going to
put that no point in there so what I
suggest to me what might be a nice
natural next step to super fight this
out in Africa 92 okay if you take out
that factor of t2 you may also like to
combine these things here at the same
time what are we going to get to you
whatever the I plus root yeah ok so I'm
going to leave that return one plus 90
mph swell like that you can see we just
combined with one faction
so now I can just divide through by this
guy which gives me can someone give me a
number 8.66 yeah which of course you can
use to get something 41 by multiplying
by our alpha venture to rue 21 26 which
gives you six point six one okay no no
admittedly it's like an introductory
example I haven't told you in like yeah
okay so you could do this with certain
like I'm here before I i I'm just going
to say either those would be okay
obviously any then context the question
will tell you what exactly at once but
this is fine like what's being assisted
like this extension to we don't care
whether you can round come on okay we're
all the important stuff is up here okay
now does it make sense there's a few
about right okay remember know everybody
needs going down hold on a second why
don't these add up to 9.8 very good so
they're going off and angles right so if
you can imagine this way can I'd Mike
where my keys go yeah famous last words
where are my keys Oh Lee and see if I
didn't have two strings if I just had
one okay here because there's no more
side to side right you've got 9.8 going
down so you've got exactly nine point
ain't going up but as I separate these
and say oh okay you can even start to
feel it in your hands right as you move
these aside the further you move though
the harder you have to pull on them
right so more and more force has to be
headed off in opposite directions right
and that's why these numbers end up we
got it's because of this thing don't you
see this this is the angle that makes it
yeah that's exactly one year because
it's why I assume I'm kind of saying you
can say a person or else we'll move it
but I don't have any I wrote I'm
introducing myself by separating
supplies okay which one is another cool
thing right like let's just put these
back the other so if they were attached
at the same
point it's okay if I just leave this guy
I'm [ __ ] talk about initial frames of
reference but if I just leave this guy
still and move one of them okay or bit
table as I move one of them right let me
just put bad when they're not table as I
drew one can you see this one that's not
moving right it has to start exerting in
the opposite direction even though it's
not going anywhere it's because of this
guy right and that's because net force
has to be 0 so you pull in this way
there's going to be this one in opposite
direction make sense cool